-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-
and Tony Award-winning actor
you know from such shows as
"Breaking Bad" and "Your Honor,"
along with films like "Argo,"
"Asteroid City," and "Trumbo."
He stars in "Argyle,"
which is in theaters
and IMAX on February 2nd.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Bryan Cranston,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You know, it's so lovely
to see you.
-Thank you.
-We've talked in the past
about your different facial hair
when you come.
And can I just say something
that I mean sincerely?
I feel like your clothes
always match
whatever your current
facial hair is.
-That's part
of the styling process, Seth.
-Yeah.
-Clearly you didn't
get that note. Yeah.
-It doesn't matter
because it's immaterial to me
because I could never
grow, like, anything
as luxurious as what
you're rocking right now.
-You can't? You can't
grow a mustache at all?
-No.
-No, I see some, you know,
5:00 shadow in there.
-You see something?
-Oh, well, no,
my makeup team puts that on.
[ Laughter ]
Gives me some masculine
confidence.
-Street cred. There you go.
Yeah.
It just kind of grows.
I don't know.
-Yeah. It's very nice.
Everything about it,
it really is.
-I don't know.
-I have some jealousy
about the whole thing.
-Really?
-I do. Like, sometimes
you come here,
you got a really good beard
sometimes.
I mean, I thought it was
one of the nicest things about
"Breaking Bad" is we saw, like,
a whole range
of different hair things.
-Yeah, I had -- I had no hair.
I had hair.
-A lot of people said it was
the writing and the acting.
For me, it was all your hair.
-It was the hair.
Or a lack thereof. Yeah.
-[ Laughs ] Or lack thereof.
Hey, I want to lament.
You are a Rams fan
I think in the same way
that I am a Steelers fan,
and I apologize that your season
also ended a little bit earlier
than you would have liked.
-It was close.
-It was close. It was
a great game against the Lions.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you actually filmed
a video on the field.
You were at the game.
-Right.
-And, uh, first I want
to show the video
because I guess
you were trying to,
you know, have some confidence
about your Rams
before the game.
Let's take a look.
-Bryan Cranston here
on the sidelines
of the Lions
versus the Rams.
And just like in the wildlife,
when rams see lions out about
they think, "You know,
they look friendly."
Go Rams.
-Alright.
-Yeah.
-You know what?
You're just supporting your
team, and then sadly they lost.
They gave it a good game.
And then the Lions
social media team...
well, I guess this
is called a troll right.
They just posted a photo of you
and said, "I won."
[ Laughter ]
-And now I can show a picture
of the 49ers and go,
"No, you didn't."
-[ Laughs ] Oh, boy.
How dare you?
That's a real Walter White.
-That's a Walter White move.
I'll come in there.
-[ Laughs ]
-Solar plexus.
-[ Stammering ]
Well, like, my YouTube algorithm
recommends "Breaking Bad" clips
to me.
That's basically
all they recommend.
-Really?
-I watched like three clips
of "Breaking Bad" a week.
Never gets old for me.
-Really?
-It's just so good.
I know, I'm just...
I know you're not here
promoting a show you did
a long time ago...
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-...but it's just amazing
to have made a show
that just holds up so well.
-It's -- It was one of the
seminal moments of my life.
I'm so proud of it,
and it changed my life.
-Yeah.
-But I will say that
I've only seen every episode
once where --
-Really?
-Yes.
And fans come up to me
and they go, "Okay,
season three, episode seven,
you did this and this and this,
and you said that.
What were you thinking
when this happened?"
I go, "I said what?"
You know, I don't really recall
because it's been 11 years.
Can you believe that? 11 years
since we were off the air.
-Since you -- Oh, my God,
that's crazy.
-Off the air. Yeah.
-Now, why --
Are you someone who only watches
the things you do
once all the time?
-Yes.
-Or is that unique to -- Okay.
-Yeah, I got to move on.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I don't spend
a lot of time in the past.
-Yeah.
-A lot of time in the present --
right here, right now, and
then with an eye on the future.
-That's a very smart way to go
because every morning I wake up
and I make my whole family
watch an old "Weekend Update."
-Is that right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And they go,
"I want that Daddy back!"
[ Laughs ]
-"Where he's got more hair!"
-"He was the nice Daddy!"
-[ Laughs ]
And I'm like, "He was nice
'cause he didn't have you yet!
That's a man free of children!"
-[ Laughs ]
-"Oh, he loves
telling jokes back then."
-Yes.
-Um...
this is such a fun film,
"Argylle."
We're going to show a clip
in between acts here,
but this is --
Uh, it's from the people
who made "The King's Man."
-"King's Man."
-Such a fun spy story.
I mean, you were in, you know,
"Argo," which is a film,
you know, which takes, I think,
like, espionage very seriously.
-Yeah.
-This has a lot more fun
with it.
Did you enjoy yourself?
-Oh, God, this is so much fun.
Matthew Vaughn who directed
"The King's Man" movies...
that it's so much fun.
It's over-the-top violence,
which it carries on
into a point of ridiculousness
and so much fun
that my character is actually,
if you look carefully
at the scene,
you might see me actually
twisting the mustache, you know?
Because I play
a nasty villain in this.
-Usually a director
would step in
if an actor twisted
a mustache and say,
"That's a little too much."
-No, he's by the monitors
going, "I want more of that!
More! More twisting!"
-Um, very, uh, incredible cast.
Uh, Sam Rockwell,
uh, Samuel L. Jackson,
Bryce Dallas Howard.
None of these people
you worked with before.
-Well, no, I did work
with Sam Rockwell.
-Okay.
-Uh, I did a movie called
"The One and Only Ivan,"
which was based on a true story
about a man who has a gorilla,
and he doesn't know what to do
with him once he grows up.
So he puts him in a,
like, a de facto circus,
and he voiced
the gorilla of Ivan.
-Gotcha.
-I would hear his voice
all the time
while I was working
in the live-action part of it,
yeah.
But that was
the only person I worked with.
And, quite frankly,
he could have done better.
-Yeah.
-I think, so...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Well, I think it's --
I think everybody agrees
that's the last time he's
voiced a gorilla in any movies.
-He will never voice
another gorilla.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, Hollywood is vicious.
-They're vicious.
-Oh!
-You blow it once
with a gorilla voice...
-Once? Out.
-Yep.
Uh, I have more
to ask you about.
We'll be right back with Bryan
after this.